congratulations to the class of 2022  unlv spring commencement was held today  at the thomas and mack this morning  there were two undergrad ceremonies more  than 3 000 students officially became  alumni we spoke with a graduate who  describes how excited she is for this  after going through all the hardships  students were put through during covent  i'm so happy to finally be graduating  especially during covet about half of my  four years was online  and so the struggle with covet  persevering through that is really  really an honor to be graduating today  the class of 2022 comes from 40  different states and 56 different  countries 86 percent though or from  right here in nevada now eight news now  is honoring all of our graduates send  photos and messages to the email on your  screen here that's pixpx 8newsnow.com  for a chance for your grad to be  featured in our newscast